[Musik]
was machen Studentinnen und Studenten
die das Unigelände wochenlang nicht
verlassen dürfen gegen die Langeweile in
ihren Wohnanlagen basteln sie Haustiere
aus Pappe und führen sie auf dem Campus
spazieren wegen Corona finden
Vorlesungen nun bald im dritten Jahr
größtenteils online statt die
Studierenden dürfen nicht raus niemand
rein von Lockdown zu corona-test zu
Lockdown alles dreht sich im Kreis diese
Verabredungen zum Krabbeln sind ein
Wortspiel den propagandaslogan so oft
testen wie möglich hat jemand
abgewandelt in so viel krabbeln wie
möglich
was witzig aussieht war Ausgangspunkt
für die größten Proteste in China seit
Jahrzehnten
es ist diese Form von kreativem Protest
der in den engen Grenzen der Diktatur
noch möglich ist die explosive Mischung
in den Unis kombiniert mit wenig
Hoffnung auf Besserung
explodierte schließlich
[Musik]
warum nimmst du ihr das leere Blatt Weg
wie gefährlich kann ein leeres Blatt
denn sein
sie war eine der ersten das leere Blatt
ist zum Symbol des Protests geworden
gegen die strengen corona-regeln gegen
die chinesische Zensur
Demokratie Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Redefreiheit
das fordern sie an der Team
fahruniversität es ist eine der Top
Elite-Unis des Landes auch Staatschef
hielen Ping hat hier studiert viele
verlassen sie gerade die Ferien zum
chinesischen Neujahr sind vorgezogen
[Musik]
wie lange können wir hier Filmen bevor
die Behörden uns aufhalten diese Frage
stellen wir uns in China immer wenn wir
irgendwo die Kamera auspacken hier sind
wir schnell genug
wie viele andere schickt auch die
teamfa-universität ihre Studentinnen und
Studenten jetzt nach Hause offiziell
heißt es damit sollten weitere
corona-infektionen vermieden werden doch
die Uni will die Studierenden wohl auch
möglichst schnell loswerden wenn die bei
ihren Familien sind verteilt auf ihre
Heimatstätte ist es natürlich viel
schwieriger dass sie sich noch mal
verabreden um gemeinsam zu protestieren
doch sie protestieren nicht nur an den
Unis sondern gleichzeitig in
verschiedenen Städten im ganzen Land
das Besondere lockdowns und
Einschränkungen treffen nicht nur eine
kleine Gruppe sondern die ganze
Bevölkerung selbst Parteikader und
Sicherheitskräfte in Shanghai verspotten
sie die Polizei
für dieses mickrige Gehalt habt ihr euch
verkauft sind eure Seelen nicht mehr
wert das ist doch lächerlich wie alt
seid ihr 20 30 und euer ganzes Leben
habt ihr an dieses System verkauft
die vollen Stadien der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft
Menschenmassen ohne Maske
für viele Chinesinnen und Chinesen ist
das ein Blick in ein normales Leben
trotz Corona hier unvorstellbar
fast drei Jahre Pandemie fast drei Jahre
null-politik Weltmeister ist China in
einer ganz anderen Disziplin im
corona-test
[Applaus]
wir wollen Freiheit im chinesischen Netz
werden diese Fotos und Videos gelöscht
doch es sind so viele dass die Zensoren
nicht hinterherkommen die Propaganda
fährt die Standardantwort auf
ausländische Kräfte hätten die Proteste
angestiftet
wer soll denn diese ausländischen Kräfte
sein Max Engels seid Ihr hier weil
ausländische Kräfte euch aufgefordert
haben nein wir haben nicht mal Zugang zu
ausländischem Internet wie sollen die
denn mit uns kommunizieren wir wollen
einfach Freiheit
eine Freiheit die es in China nicht gibt
seit Corona noch viel weniger
ein Wohnhausbrand im Nordwesten des
Landes war ein weiterer Auslöser der
Proteste
viele glauben dass die Menschen dort
starben weil sie nicht rechtzeitig
rauskamen das Haus soll unter Lockdown
gewesen sein Ausgänge abgeriegelt
für die Opfer bringen Sie Blumen und
Kerzen
ein bisschen Wachs auf den Steinen das
ist alles was übrig ist von den
Protesten an diesem Ort in der ganzen
Straße stehen mehrere Polizeiautos und
es gibt viele Aufpasser in Zivil auch
wir werden während wir hier Filmen
beobachtet von mehreren Männern
immer unter Beobachtung für uns bleibt
das heute ohne Konsequenzen für andere
nicht nicht für den reporterkollegen der
BBC der von der Demonstration in
Shanghai berichtete
nicht für diese Demonstrantinnen und
Demonstranten
[Musik]
auch im Nachhinein berichten viele von
Anrufen der Polizei oder besuchen der
Staatssicherheit
hier kontrollieren Beamte die Handys von
Passanten sie löschen Fotos und Videos
der Proteste und suchen nach verbotenen
Messenger Apps
Chinas Griff in die krisenwerkzeugkiste
der Diktatur zensieren kontrollieren
wegsperren
so ging es auch ihm
brückenmann Bridge man so wird er
genannt
kurz vor dem Parteitag der
Kommunistischen Partei im Oktober machte
eine seltene Protestaktion an einer
Straßenkreuzung in Peking wir wollen
keine corona-tests wir wollen
Lebensmittel steht da zum Beispiel
die Banner des Bridge man an der Brücke
hier hinter mir die wurden schnell
abgehängt er wurde verhaftet doch seine
Botschaften die verbreiten sich im
ganzen Land auch viele von denen die
jetzt auf die Straße gehen die sagen das
sein Mut sie inspiriert habe sich das
jetzt zu trauen
statt Demonstranten marschiert auf den
Straßen von Chinas Großstädten jetzt das
Militär
die chinesische Führung hat hartes
Durchgreifen angekündigt ob diese Videos
wirklich aktuell sind lässt sich nicht
in jedem Fall überprüfen ihren Zweck die
Menschen von weiteren Protesten
abzuschrecken erfüllen sie zumindest für
den Moment